-Your daughters, 12 and 6?
-Yes.
-Alice is the 12-year-old?
-Does she get
any comedy education
living with two
very funny parents?
-She is.
I think she --
It´s funny because at 12,
they used such --
They used to be my only source
of stories for programs
like this, but now
I can´t do it anymore,
because they catch me.
-Oh, they don´t...
-Like, Alice came home
one day and was like,
"Hey, a friend of mine´s sister
showed me, like,
a long YouTube video of
you telling stories about me
on different talk shows."
I was like, "I don´t know what
you´re talking about."
#Fakenews.
[ Laughter ]
But yeah, it´s cool.
You´ll see like, you know, Ash,
like, when he gets bigger,
you get so excited that you get
really like, "I´m gonna..."
They´re bigger, "I´m going to
show you ´Back to the Future.´"
-Yeah.
-You get to show them movies
and stuff that you love.
And she´s, you know, getting
a really great
comedy education on her own.
She -- Over one summer,
she binge-watched all of
"The Andy Griffith Show" twice.
-Wow.
That´s a real deep cut.
-That´s a deep cut.
All of "The Dick Van Dyke Show."
I mean, these are
fundamental principles.
-I mean, just to go --
A kid in today´s age,
to say "I will watch
black and white comedy."
-Yes. Black and white --
gentle black and white comedy.
-Gentle black and white comedy.
-Yeah, She watched all
of the American "Office"
this summer.
-Great.
-And I was like,
those little seasons were,
like, 26 episodes.
-Yeah.
-She watched it in like, a week.
And she came to me and she was
like, "What should I watch now?"
And I was like,
"Well, you´re 12 now.
A lot of people like ´30 Rock.´"
[ Laughter ]
So she goes to watch "30 Rock,"
and she watched a couple
and she came back out to me
and she was like,
"It´s too weird for me."
And I was like ´Oh, is it --
make you feel weird
´cause Mommy had to,
I don´t know, like, pretend to
be in love with somebody
who wasn´t Daddy?"
And she was just like, "No,
it´s just too weird for me."
And I was like, "Oh,
you mean like tonally."
[ Laughter ]
And so I was like, "Okay."
So, I had to take that hit.
Like, that was
a hard motherly hit...
-Yeah.
-...to take.
And she´s like,
"So, what should I watch?"
And, I was like, well,
you know, what about
´Parks and Recreation´?
You might really like that."
And she was like, "Oh,
I watched all of it already."
And then, it´s so hard
for me not to be, like,
"Get in your room
and watch ´30 Rock.´"
I was gonna spank her.
I felt like that woman
in "Big Little Lies"
when she found out that, like,
Zoe Kravitz gave her kid
the pill, birth control.
And I was like,
"You come to me for that!
You don´t go to Aunt Amy
and Mike Schur!"
[ Laughter ]
-"I just like my ensemble comedy
from Aunt Amy."
-"I like a gentle Mike Schur
sensibility.
´30 Rock´ is overstuffed."
Okay, fine.
-Did you --
Have they seen previews of
the early work of "Mean Girls"?
-Yeah, they´ve been coming
to rehearsals
every now and then,
for the musical.
That is exciting, because
that is the first thing that
Jeff and I have done that
they are truly excited about.
-That´s great.
-And the little one came
and watched, you know,
a full run-through last spring
and at six years old --
at five then --
just all the wrong takeaways.
She was just like --
She was going back
to her preschool being like,
"Let´s play ´Mean Girls.´
I´m Regina.
I yell at you."
Like, it was just like,
"I´m a sassy teenager."
I was like, no, you gotta --
It´s very positive at its core.
A very positive message.
Nope.
I get it.
[ Laughter ]
-Well this is --
I think that the takeaway is
be careful about the work
you create over the years.
because your children will
one day take the wrong messages
from it.
-Yes, yeah.
-Yeah, well, I will do the same.
Thank you so much for being
here, and congrats.
-I can´t wait to see it.